うんかわかりませんけどねその.そうめん食ってるんですけど実は昨日
めちゃくちゃ事件が起きました皆さん覚えてますでしょうか
去年のクリスマス僕の家にストーカーの女性が審理してきました
その女性は逮捕され今はもう大丈夫なんですけれどもあんな大々的にニュースに出た後
にでも
なんとなんとですねああ
また
やらそうな人が言いましたいやちょっとね今回なんかすごいやばい気がしてます舞結構
いいんですけど
今回もなんかまた怪しい完全すごくてなんかねその中女性が来るとかなんだかわから
なくてっていうが
でをな男の子が来るのもなんか分からないですって言うだいたい12くる人ってなんか
ちゃんとした理由があってくるともわかるんですけど今回打つに来た
ちょっと山そうな人はおじいさんでした夜にちょっと事件が起きたんですけどちょっと
急に来たにと中間にあるんですけどまずは vdr
どうかもよ
いうのは受け付けていないんで
[音楽]
んだって言う
うん
今日は
どこにだっ
2ヶ月以
5月4日
シネマズで声マジで怖いまずで声マジで怖者僕ねん
じゃバービヤ俺の経験増
ストーカーっているわけわかんないこと言うんだよ姉が事実かどうかも分からなければ
正直ね
それも調子付かなかったんです
今度来たらまず範囲という気でいかがだったでしょうか
いや何か僕はもう何か実際家に入られる恐怖を吸ってるんであの時ほどの恐怖はなかっ
たんですけどそれでもやっぱ強いっすね完全になら言ってることがおかしいなんですか
ねも超そうなんか常識じゃないんだろうな多分
こんだけ何度も何度もゆちに来たら迷惑です
ってことを言ってるのにまだ来るって事はもう
そういうことなんですよそういうことなんですちょっと考えられない人なんですね
もうしつこい館でもすごい迷惑で動画動画撮れバイクからも結構すごくても絶対いる
でしょ出て来い始めちゃって出れば弾み価値を置いてでもここでなら僕が良いナスって
言ったらモチロンすること帰らなくなるから
僕はいませんって嘘ついてそれでも結構なない子がいたんですけど一回帰らせることが
できたんですけど
次期待
ああああああ
許さないと触れないで本気ですや怖いよー
わけわかんないなぁでも実は6くるんだろうわかんない
何が目的なんですかちょっと謎の多いしてこのエロスのじいちゃんが見てるか分から
ないんですけど準備くるのが本当にやめてください
もう何度も何度も言っております後何度も何も動画にしておりますよ女を
ネタ提供ありがとうございますやったらやっぱり怖いです
止めていただきたいと思っております恐怖で震えたグラフの始まりでした
yeah
me
バッハ